David Boder: (In English) Spool number 133 (hundred thirty three) September 20, 1946 in Munich at the Funkenkaserne in a camp for detention of DP’s, who are here in a number of about five thousand (5,000) in a tremendous installation of the German, hm, of the former German Army. An installation that was welcomed here to some extent with great factory installations and that was the Funkenkaserne - part of the signal corps of the Germans. Though the windows I see children playing, like children do play everywhere, all kinds of games, under the direction of teachers and alone. And there the barracks in back all the way around. And here I have before me a, a woman, which is Mrs. Anna Braun, who is here with a group of about 500 Mennonites, who live in one block, which I intend to visit later. Men and women together in one community – also – in one community and in one room, separated, as I am being told, with some kind of thin material and there a two-story bunks.
David Boder: (auf deutsch) Also, Frau Braun, wollen Sie mir sagen, wie heißen Sie und wie alt sind Sie und wo sind Sie geboren?
Anna Braun: Ich heiße Anna Braun, vierzig (40) Jahre alt, geboren in Einlage, Zaporozhe, Ukraine.
David Boder: Ja. Wenn Sie Schwierigkeiten haben, sagen Sie es ruhig auf russisch.
Anna Braun: Ja, gut.
David Boder: In Zaporozhe, Ukraine – dort sind Sie geboren, nicht wahr?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Wer waren Ihre Eltern, Frau Braun?
Anna Braun: Meine Eltern waren, hm, .... Cornelius Peter und meine Mutter ....
David Boder: Ja, also ich brauch nicht den Namen, was war ihre Beschäftigung?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Was hat Ihre Familie sich mit beschäftigt?
Anna Braun: Mein Vater war Mühlen Besitzer.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Hat eine große Dampfmühle gehabt in Tartiza.
David Boder: Also er war nicht Bauer?
Anna Braun: Nein.
David Boder: Jetzt haben Sie mit sich zwei (2) Kinder, wie alt sind die Kinder?
Anna Braun: Mein älteste Tochter, Stieftochter, ist zwanzig (20) Jahre alt und die Jüngere zehn (10) Jahre alt.
David Boder: Waren Sie zwei (2) Mal verheiratet, Frau Braun?
Anna Braun: Nein, ich habe im Jahr neunzehn hundert fünf und dreißig (1935) einen Witwer geheiratet.
David Boder: Und Sie haben seine Tochter mit sich auch genommen?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Also, Frau Braun, wollen Sie mit jetzt bitte erzählen, wo waren Sie, wenn der Krieg angefangen ist und was ist Ihnen während des Krieges, sozusagen (unverständlich) passiert?
Anna Braun: Ich arbeitete in Zaporozhe als technische Zeichnerin in Dnieper Stahlwerken. (Pause) Wie der Krieg anfing, wurden Viele aus dem Betriebe entlassen. Ich blieb bis ... der Rückzug kam, das heißt, bis das ganze Werk den Rückzug antrat.
David Boder: Das heißt evakuieren?
Anna Braun: Ja, evakuiert werden musste, ja. Da das Werk sich am rechten Ufer befand .....
David Boder: Am rechten Ufer des Dniepers?
Anna Braun: ... am rechten Ufer das Dniepers befand, mein Haus aber am linken Ufer war, bin ich zurück zu meiner Familie ans linke Ufer.
David Boder: Das ist also nach Osten.
Anna Braun: Ja, nach Osten.
David Boder: Ja, der Dieper fließt südwärts, nicht wahr?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: So Sie gehen näher zu den Russen zurück.
David Boder: Ja, die Deutschen kamen vom Westen.
Anna Braun: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Und Sie gingen auf die andere Seite zurück.
Anna Braun: Ja. Also das wusste ich damals nicht, war das an der Russen Seite oder an der deutschen Seite. Auf jeden Fall, wie ich dann nach Hause kam, da war ich zwei Tage zu Hause und dann kam die Deutschen dahin.
David Boder: Wer war mit Ihnen zu Hause?
Anna Braun: Bei mir zu Hause war meine Stiefmutter und meine beiden Töchter.
David Boder: Und wo war Ihr Mann?
Anna Braun: Mein Mann würde schon im Jahre neunzehn hundert sechs und dreißig (1936) am sechzehnten (16.) Oktober verhaftet.
David Boder: Warum? Erzählen Sie mir bitte mehr Einzelheiten, die ganze Geschichte. Warum wurde Ihr Mann verhaftet und auch andere Leute von Ihrer Sekte?
Anna Braun: Warum? Die Gründe erfuhren wir nie, aber es war wohl unserer Religion halber. Denn ... mein Vater, der schon neunzehn hundert neunzehn (1919) von einer Bande erschlagen wurde, dann heiratete meine Mutter den zweiten (2.) Mann, also unseren Stiefvater.
David Boder: Also Ihre Mutter heiratet einen zweiten (2.) Mann?
Anna Braun: Ja. Er war eigentlich auch mein Onkel.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Und mein Stiefvater war Ältester der (unverständlich) Mennoniten Gemeinde, der Gemeinde.
Anna Braun: Er wurde schon mit meiner Mutter im Jahre neunzehn hundert neun und zwanzig nach dem Ural raus verschickt.
David Boder: Ja. Ihr Stiefvater wurde nach dem Ural verschickt?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
David Boder: Und.
Anna Braun: Das war der Religion halber, weil er der Älteste der ....
David Boder: Mennoniten.
Anna Braun: ... der Mennoniten Gemeinde war.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Da ... dort blieb er fünf (5) Jahre lang.
David Boder: Und Sie blieben zu Hause.
Anna Braun: Und ich bin zu Hause ... und erst wie mein Vater zurück kam, habe ich geheiratet.
David Boder: Also Ihr Vater kam zurück vom Ural?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Mit Ihrer Stief... mit Ihrer Mutter?
Anna Braun: Mit der Mutter.
David Boder: Ja. Er hat also die Strafe durch gemacht und dann wurde zurück geschickt?
Anna Braun: Ja, er hatte wahrscheinlich eine Strafe.
David Boder: Ja, er wurde verschickt und kam zurück.
Anna Braun: Er wurde verschickt und kam zurück.
David Boder: Wann kam er zurück?
Anna Braun: Er kam neunzehn hundert fünf und dreißig (1935) zurück.
David Boder: Was hat er Ihnen erzählt? Wie ist es ihm dort im Ural gegangen?
Anna Braun: Er persönlich hat immer im Büro gearbeitet im Ural.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Sehr schlechtes Essen bekommen, auch alle Anderen, die dort noch waren. Es waren dort verschiedene Nationen im Ural. Die Meisten sind dort verhungert und gestorben.
David Boder: Also Ihr Vater und Ihre Mutter kamen zurück – das war Ihr Stiefvater in fünf und dreißig (35)?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Also ... war er dann mit Ihnen, wenn die Deutschen kamen?
Anna Braun: Nein.
David Boder: Ja, in fünf Jahren ...
Anna Braun: Nachdem er drei (3) Jahre zu Hause war, das heißt, in Einlage war, er hatte kein Haus mehr, das Haus hatte man ihm genommen. Also, nachdem er drei (3) Jahre wieder hier in Einlage war ...
David Boder: Ist Einlage der Name der Stadt?
Anna Braun: Ja, Einlage ist der Name des Dorfes.
David Boder: Ja, hat das Dorf einen Deutschen Namen gehabt?
Anna Braun: Einlage .... Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Und wie hat sich das auf russisch genannt?
Anna Braun: Kitchkas.
David Boder: Kitchka, Nun weiter.
Anna Braun: Nachdem er drei (3) Jahre in Kitchkas war hat man ihn wieder verhaftet und ins Gefängnis gesteckt. Und bis heute haben wir von ihm nichts mehr gehört.
David Boder: Sie sagten etwas von einem Todesurteil. Wie gewiss war das?
Anna Braun: Also fünf und dreißig (35) habe ich erst geheiratet, in sechs und dreißig (36) haben sie den Mann genommen, nach sechs (6) Monaten.
David Boder: Welchen Mann haben sie genommen?
Anna Braun: Meinen Mann.
David Boder: Oh, das war Ihr Mann.
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: In fünf und dreißig (35) haben Sie sich verheiratet?
David Boder: Und in sechs und dreißig (36) hat man den Mann genommen?
Anna Braun: Hat man meinen Mann genommen
David Boder: Haben Sie schon das Kind gehabt?
Anna Braun: Ja, drei Monate .....
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: ... alt war mein Kind.
David Boder: Nun?
Anna Braun: Dann hat man eines nachts meinen Mann geholt, nachdem man drei (3) Stunden lang das ganze Haus durchsucht hat.
David Boder: Ja, was haben sie gesucht?
Anna Braun: Man hat ausländische Briefe mit genommen, aber sonst weiß ich nicht wonach man gesucht hat.
David Boder: Also was für ausländische Briefe waren dies?
Anna Braun: Wir hatten nur die Briefe unserer Verwandten aus Amerika.
David Boder: Ah, von den Mennoniten in Amerika.
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Aha, nun.
Anna Braun: Die Briefe hat man alle genommen und nicht mehr zurück gegeben. Dann ging auch mein Mann und nach sechs (6) monatlicher Gefängnishaft wurde er vom Kharkover Kriegstribunal zum Tode verurteilt.
David Boder: Waren Sie bei Gericht?
Anna Braun: Nein, man hat mich nicht zugelassen.
David Boder: Waren Sie in Kharkov?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Und wer hat Ihnen gesagt, was für ein Urteil er bekommen hat?
Anna Braun: In Kharkov im Kriegstribunal in Kriegstribunal Akt hat man es mir gesagt. Den dritten (3.) Juli neunzehn hundert sieben und dreißig 1937) hat man es mir gesagt, dass das Urteil im Juni sieben und dreißig (37) in, .von Moskau bestätigt wurde.
David Boder: Ja. Haben Sie Ihren Mann nach dem Urteil gesehen?
Anna Braun: Nein.
David Boder: Hat man Sie nicht zugelassen?
David Boder: Aha, und dann?
Anna Braun: Dann ...... das Urteil wurde aber in Zaporozhe, Russland ausgesprochen. Von Zaporozhe kam mein Mann nach Dnepropetrovsk, dort ....
David Boder: Aber Sie sagten was mit Kharkov?
Anna Braun: Das Kharkover Kriegstribunal hat ihn in Zaporozhe gerichtet.
David Boder: Oh ja, nun?
Anna Braun: Dann kam er von Zaporozhe nach dem Gericht nach Dnepropetrovsk. Dorthin habe ich ... habe ich noch im Juni – Mitte Juni – können für ihn Essen abgeben.
David Boder: Was sind Sie da jeden Tag hin gegangen?
Anna Braun: Nein, ich bin jede Woche dorthin gefahren.
David Boder: Ja und dann?
Anna Braun: Habe ... habe ihm das Essen und reine Wäsche gebracht.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Und haben jedes Mal von mir diese Sachen angenommen und jedes Mal hat sich mein Mann auf dem Zettel, den ich schreiben musste ....
Anna Braun: ... wo ich auch die Sachen aufgezählt habe, was ich hinein gebe, da hat mein Mann sich unterschreiben müssen, dass ich ... ‚diese Sachen hab ich alle erhalten’.
David Boder: Hat er auch die schmutzige Wäsche zurück schicken können?
Anna Braun: Ja, die schmutzige Wäsche hat er zurück geschickt.
David Boder: Ja und?
Anna Braun: Die waren immer ... sehr schmutzig.
David Boder: Warum?
Anna Braun: Einmal waren sie so schmutzig und so ziemlich ...
David Boder: Was heißt ziemlich?
Anna Braun: Blutflecken waren drin.
David Boder: Nun.
Anna Braun: Vorher habe ich das nicht bemerkt, sie waren nur verschwitzt und gelb. Ich habe ihm aber jede Woche neue Wäsche gebracht.
David Boder: Reine Wäsche oder neue Wäsche?
Anna Braun: Reine Wäsche.
David Boder: Und nun?
Anna Braun: Jedenfalls also hat er es immer erhalten. Dann ... es .... war Ende Juni, fuhr ich wieder nach Dnepropetrovsk, um ihm Essen und Wäsche zu bringen, da war er nicht mehr da.
David Boder: Und was hat man Ihnen gesagt?
Anna Braun: Da hat man mir gesagt (unverständlich – kein deutsches Wort)
David Boder: (wiederholt das gleiche Wort)
Anna Braun: Dann bin ich sofort nach Kharkow gefahren ins ......
David Boder: Zur Behörde?
Anna Braun: Zur Behörde und Kriegstribunal und dort im militärischen Akt hat man nach gesehen und mir gesagt, dass diese Sache bekannt ist und dass das Urteil im Juni von Moskau bestätigt wurde. Da fragte ich, was ich noch machen könnte, denn ich war schon drei (3) Mal in Moskau gewesen. Da sagte man mir ‘(Russisches Wort) klingt wie “niczewa”.’ Und seit dem weiß ich nichts mehr von meinem Mann. Es sind .... am sechzehnten (16.) Oktober werden es 10 Jahre.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir, Frau Braun, waren andere Leute mit Ihrem Mann verurteilt oder war er alleine bei Gericht?
Anna Braun: Es wurden zehn Mann zu gleich verurteilt auf dem .... an dem Tage, die alle in Kitchkas – Einlage wohnten. Es waren alle außer drei (3) Mann ... also sieben (7) Mann waren Mennoniten und drei (3) Mann nicht Mennoniten.
David Boder: Wieso sind sie alle in einem Prozess zusammen gekommen?
Anna Braun: Das habe ich niemals erfahren, denn jene drei (3) Nicht-Mennoniten habe ich nicht gekannt und auch niemals gehört, dass mein Mann sie gekannt hat.
David Boder: Was war die Beschuldigung? (spricht einen Satz in Russisch)
Anna Braun: Man hat immer gesagt, wer war „Gesta”, aber sonst weiß ich nichts.
David Boder: Was ist „Gesta”?
Anna Braun: Das ist die Ges ... dieser (unverständlich)?
David Boder: Oh, hat Ihr Mann für .... im “Ges” gearbeitet?
Anna Braun: Mein Mann arbeitet im Haupt Büro von Ges.
David Boder: Was war er dort?
Anna Braun: Er war Ökonomist.
David Boder: Hat er Ökonomie studiert?
Anna Braun: Nein, das hat er nicht.
David Boder: Aha, aber er hat in der ökonomischen Abteilung gearbeitet?
Anna Braun: Ja, er hat dort gearbeitet und hatte viel Praktik.
David Boder: Also weiter nun, Frau Braun. (Pause) Also dann sind Sie allein geblieben. Haben Sie je eine Bescheinigung bekommen, dass Sie Witwe sind?
Anna Braun: Niemals.
David Boder: Man hat Ihnen dort keine Bescheinigung nicht gegeben?
Anna Braun: Nein.
David Boder: Nun betrachten Sie die Mennoniten als Witwe?
Anna Braun: Auch nicht. Denn ich bin immer ganz .... ganz davon überzeugt, dass mein Mann nicht tot ist. Aber sowie meine älteste Tochter und auch viele Mennoniten – (räuspert sich) weil wir eben so einen festen Glauben haben, dass Gott so was nicht zulassen kann - also glauben wir auch an Wunder, dass vielleicht auf irgend eine Art mein Mann doch noch irgendwo leben könnte. Mein Tochter sagt immer, die Hoffnung darf Dir niemand rauben.
David Boder: Also unter solchen Bedingungen würden Sie sich nicht verheiraten dürfen?
Anna Braun: Nein.
David Boder: Verheiraten sich Witwen bei den Mennoniten im Allgemeinen?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Ja. Nun also – was hat dann passiert als die Deutschen kamen ? Sie gingen also auf die andere Seite des Dnieper, sagten Sie, zu Ihrer Familie.
David Boder: Und?
Anna Braun: Hm (räuspert sich), wie die Deutschen kamen dann dauerte die Front ... das war dann gerade dort die Front, wo wir wohnten. Das dauerte wohl ein ein-halb (1 ½) Monate lang, dann mussten wir doch unser Haus und Hof verlassen und evakuiert werden von dort. Aber nicht weit, wir kamen nur zwanzig (20) Kilometer ab von unserem Haus und Hof.
David Boder: Hm.
Anna Braun: Nachdem dann wieder die Russen zurück gingen und die Deutschen vor, gingen wir in unser Haus zurück. Vieles war kaputt, aber in unserem Haus war, außer den Glasscheiben, nichts kaputt.
David Boder: Also wie lange waren Sie weg vom Hause?
Anna Braun: Wir waren einen ganzen Monat vom Hause weg.
David Boder: Also was ist passiert? Die Deutschen kamen und dann sind die Russen wieder zurück gekommen?
Anna Braun: Dann .... Also kamen die Deutschen und die Russen gingen zurück. So blieben wir wohl ein Jahr da. Dann kamen die Russen wieder.
David Boder: Aha. Also Sie blieben ein Jahr unter den Deutschen und sind nicht weggegangen?
Anna Braun: Wir sind nicht weggegangen. Dann, wie die Russen wieder kamen und das Geschieße wieder anfing, die Front sicher da wieder sehr lange aufhielt bei uns und schon sehr viele Häuser zerstört wurden und es schon Todesopfer gab, da mussten wir wieder unser Haus und Hof verlassen. Das heißt, wir wurden in den Zug geladen .....
David Boder: Bei wem?
Anna Braun: Bei den Deutschen. In den Zug geladen und wussten nicht, ... wohin es geht. Es ging also ab.
David Boder: Nach dem Westen?
Anna Braun: .... nach dem Westen.
David Boder: Wollen Sie mir etwas erzählen von die Zügen und wie wurden Sie geladen? Wie viele Leute waren sie in dem Zug und was hat man Ihnen gesagt?
Anna Braun: Man hat uns gesagt, wir dürften nur unser Essen mitnehmen. In den Zügen waren fünf und dreißig (35) Personen in einem Viehwagen.
David Boder: Fünf und dreißig (35)?
Anna Braun: Fünf und dreißig (35) Personen und dann noch alle Sachen.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Die Kranken wurde extra in Personenwagen geladen. Es waren darunter auch Schwerkranke.
David Boder: Waren das alle Mennoniten?
Anna Braun: Es waren .... nein, es waren verschiedene Leute, auch Mennoniten, auch Russen, auch Ukrainer. Russen und Ukrainer waren ganz Wenige, aber viele Volksdeutschen waren da ... von verschiedene .................. verschiedene .............. Stellen, auch Flüchtlinge.
David Boder: Also mit Volksdeutschen meinen Sie die, die für Generationen in Saratov und dort gelebt haben, die deutschen Kolonisten, nicht wahr?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Die waren doch nicht alle Mennoniten, nicht wahr?
Anna Braun: Nein. Nein, nein.
David Boder: Das waren Volksdeutsche. Also sie hatten ungefähr fünf und dreißig (35) Personen in einem Viehwagen geladen ....
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: .....und mit den ganzen Sachen und so wurden Sie zurück geschickt.
David Boder: Was haben Sie Ihnen zu Essen gegeben? Und wo ... wie hat man die Toilette besorgt?
Anna Braun: Toiletten gab’s keine. Man ist stundenlang gefahren; anschließlich an einem Bahnhof, wenn der Zug anhielt, dann ging eben alles hinaus. Solange gab es eben keine Gelegenheit „hinaus zu gehen”. Für die Kinder hatten dann ... hatten die Frauen ihre Töpfe mit, nicht, die das dann zum Fenster ausgossen ... während der Fahrt.
David Boder: Was für Fenster gibt es in solchen Wagons?
Anna Braun: Es gibt in diesen Wagons oben ganz kleine Fenster, die man ganz verschließen kann oder öffnen.
David Boder: Nun und wohin sind Sie dann gekommen?
Anna Braun: Dann kamen .... kamen wir .....
David Boder: Waren da Bänke in diesen Wagons?
Anna Braun: Nein, Bänke waren keine, man saß auf seinen Bündeln.
Anna Braun: Also das war die deutsche Evakuation?
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Ja. Nun weiter.
David Boder: Man saß auf seinen Sachen – auf Koffern, Betten .....
Anna Braun: Koffer, Betten und Bündeln?
David Boder: ... und Bündeln, ja.
Anna Braun: Man schlief abwechselnd auf diesen Sachen, denn die Leute fielen manchmal um.
David Boder: Warum?
Anna Braun: Weil .. während der Fahrt wurden doch die Türen verschlossen, dann konnte niemand hinaus und die Luft wurde zu eng.
David Boder: Und weiter.
Anna Braun: Dann kamen wir an ..... wir sind vierzehn (14) Tage gereist bis Lipmanstadt.
David Boder: Wo ist das?
Anna Braun: Lipmanstadt ist in Polen.
David Boder: Oh ja. Wie hat das in Polnisch geheißen?
Anna Braun: Lwow.
David Boder: Oh, Lwow, Oh ja. .
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Weiter.
Anna Braun: Dort waren wir in einem Durchgangslager.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Dort hat man sich gebadet, umgezogen. Da kriegten wir heiße Speisen und dann ging es weiter bis Neustadt, das ist in West Preußen.
David Boder: Neustadt, West Preußen.
Anna Braun: Neustadt, West Preußen. Dort in Neustadt, das war ein sehr großes Lager. Dort wurden auch, dort wurde auch unser Transport verlagert. Es waren in dem Lager über zwei tausend (2000) Mann.
David Boder: Wer waren die? Waren da Juden darunter?
Anna Braun: Nein, Juden waren keine.
David Boder: Wer war dort? Waren Zigeuner dort?
Anna Braun: Es waren verschiedene, verschiedene Nationen ...
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: ... außer Juden.
David Boder: Ich sagte vorher – waren da Zigeuner?
Anna Braun: Zigeuner?
David Boder: Zigeuner haben Sie nicht bemerkt?
Anna Braun: Nein, Zigeuner habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
David Boder: Waren da Russen?
Anna Braun: Russen.
David Boder: Franzosen?
Anna Braun: Franzosen.
David Boder: Ja. Und nun, wie beschreiben Sie nun das Leben in solch einem Lager?
Anna Braun: Im Lager war das Leben furchtbar. Erstens Mal – solche Lager waren furchtbar voller Wanzen. Das war das Schlimmste in diesen Lagern, die Wanzen. Man konnte nachts nicht schlafen, so arg waren die Wanzen. Und es schien so, man konnte sie auch nicht vertreiben. Man hatte nicht die Mittel diese Wanzen wegzukriegen.
David Boder: Nun erzählen Sie mal, wie ist der Tag in solch einem Lager vergangen? Wann sind Sie aufgestanden?
Anna Braun: Das war verschieden, die in die Arbeiten gingen, die mussten früh auf.
David Boder: Und wer musste arbeiten? Wer hat gearbeitet?
Anna Braun: Arbeiten mussten alle – junge Leute bis zu vierzig (40) Jahren, die mussten arbeiten.
David Boder: Also mussten Sie arbeiten.
Anna Braun: Ich auch.
David Boder: Ihre Tochter?
Anna Braun: Meine Tochter.
David Boder: Und die Kleine?
Anna Braun: Die Kleinste – nein, die hat nicht gearbeitet.
David Boder: Die war ja damals noch nicht zehn (10) Jahre alt.
Anna Braun: Die ist jetzt zehn (10). Damals war sie ....
David Boder: Acht (8)?
Anna Braun: Drei und vierzig (43) war sie .... sieben (7) Jahre alt.
David Boder: Was hat sie denn den ganzen Tag – die Kleine getan?
Anna Braun: Weil in einem Zimmer haben – ungefähr so gross wie Dieses ....
David Boder: Das ist ungefähr ..... vier (4) Meter bei sechs (6).
Anna Braun: Da zehn (10) bis zwölf (12) Mann wohnten ....
David Boder: Was heißt Mann? Frauen ....
Anna Braun: Frauen und auch Männer und auch Kinder ....
David Boder: Männer, Frauen und Kinder im selben Zimmer?
Anna Braun: Männer, Frauen und Kinder im selben Zimmer.
David Boder: Und wie viele Männer waren in Ihrem Zimmer, wo Sie wohnten?
Anna Braun: Indem Zimmer war ein Mann und .... das Andere waren Frauen und Kinder.
David Boder: Und wie waren die Betten? Übereinander in drei (3) Stock?
Anna Braun: Nein, die Betten waren zwei (2) stöckig.
David Boder: Ja, zwei (2) stöckige Betten?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Hat der Mann dort eine Frau gehabt?
Anna Braun: Ja, der Mann hatte dort seine Frau.
David Boder: Nun was?
Anna Braun: Nun und so blieb immer jemand im Zimmer, wo ich konnte die Tochter lassen.
David Boder: So nun blieb die Kleine dort mit jemandem im Zimmer?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Hat die Kleine welche Schule dort gehabt, welche Spiele, welchen Unterricht, welche Zerstreuung?
Anna Braun: Nein, die Kleine hatte dort keine Schule. Und auf dem Hof versammelten sich die Kinder und dort haben sie dann ...
David Boder: Die Zeit verbracht.
Anna Braun: ..... die Zeit verbracht.
David Boder: Ja, weiter.
Anna Braun: Ich arbeitete .....
David Boder: Also, wenn Sie aufstehen, bekamen Sie etwas zu essen?
Anna Braun: Ja, am Morgen holte man sich das Essen aus der Großküche.
David Boder: Und was war das?
Anna Braun: Das war Kaffee und Schwarzbrot.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Die andere kalte Verpflegung kriegte man einmal in der Woche.
David Boder: Und was war das?
Anna Braun: Das war .... war Butter ....
David Boder: Margarine?
Anna Braun: Marmelade. Nein, das war auch Butter, manchmal Margarine, manchmal Marmelade.
David Boder: Etwas Wurst?
Anna Braun: Etwas Wurst.
David Boder: Nun also da haben Sie den Kaffee. Haben Sie Appell gehabt. Hat man jeden Morgen abgestimmt, wie viele Leute im Lager sind?
Anna Braun: Nein, das hat man nicht. Man hat vielleicht ..... in jedem Zimmer war ein Stubenältester, vielleicht hat der das müssen sagen.
David Boder: Aha. Aber sie hatten keinen Appell?
Anna Braun: Nein, hatten wir nicht.
David Boder: Nun und dann gehen Sie zur Arbeit. Was haben Sie gearbeitet?
Anna Braun: Ich persönlich kam nur einmal in der Woche nach Hause, weil ich auswärts arbeitete.
David Boder: Oh, und Ihre ältere Tochter?
Anna Braun: Und meine ältere Tochter arbeitete dort im Lager.
David Boder: Wo arbeiteten Sie auswärts und wo wohnten Sie?
Anna Braun: Ich arbeitete sechs und dreißig Kilometer außerhalb von Neustadt.
David Boder: Als was?
Anna Braun: Als technische Zeichnerin.
David Boder: Oh, Sie waren ja technische Zeichnerin zu Hause. So arbeiteten Sie als technische Zeichnerin für die Deutschen?
Anna Braun: Auch.
David Boder: Ja. Und was haben Sie gezeichnet?
Anna Braun: Ich habe Diagramme und Kurvenzeichnungen gezeichnet.
David Boder: Wofür?
Anna Braun: Was war für eine Versuchsanstalt. Dass ich nicht einmal .... ich kriegte nicht einmal die Benennung der Zeichnung zu sehen.
David Boder: Aha.
Anna Braun: Also wusste ich nicht, wofür ich es zeichnete.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir, Frau Braun, die Mennoniten wollen keinen Krieg und haben keine Waffen, nicht wahr?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Nun ist es nicht ungefähr dasselbe für den Krieg zu arbeiten, wenn man Kriegsmaterial baut?
Anna Braun: Es ist bestimmt auch ..... wenn man es bewusst tut, ist es bestimmt dasselbe.
David Boder: Aber Sie haben nicht gewusst, was Sie getan haben?
Anna Braun: Nein, ich habe es nicht gewusst, ich weiß auch heute nicht, ob ich für den Krieg gearbeitet habe oder nicht.
David Boder: Weiter, nun?
Anna Braun: Dann .... kam ich also am Sonnabend zurück ins Lager, dort blieb ich dann den Sonntag und Sonntag abends ging es dann wieder zurück an die Ostsee, direkt an der Ostsee arbeitete ich.
David Boder: Oh, Sie arbeiten an der Ostsee. Also Neustadt ist dort neben Königsberg?
Anna Braun: Ja, oh ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Und Neustadt ist auch gar nicht weit von Danzig.
David Boder: Aha.
Anna Braun: Und diese Versuchsanstalt hieß, hm, Versuchsanstalt Grossendorf. So hieß sie.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Keinen anderen Namen.
David Boder: Und wie haben sich die Deutschen gegen ..... Ihnen gegenüber benommen?
Anna Braun: Sehr verschieden. Es gab solche, die sich gut benahmen, aber es gab auch solche, die sich sehr schlecht benahmen.
David Boder: Bitte erklären Sie.
Anna Braun: Also während der Arbeit da hat man mich gut behandelt, weil man mit meiner Arbeit zufrieden war. Ich habe nämlich mein ganzes Leben sehr gerne gezeichnet. Und daher machte ich meine Arbeit gut. Also als technische Zeichnerin wurde ich immer gut behandelt. Aber wenn man erst zurück in Lager kam ... vom Lagerführer wurde man nicht gut behandelt.
David Boder: Hat er die Leute geschlagen?
Anna Braun: Ja, er hat auch die Leute geschlagen.
David Boder: Wofür?
Anna Braun: Es gab Solche, die der Lagerdisziplin nicht gehorchen wollten, dafür wurden sie bestraft, dafür kriegten sie Schläge vom Lagerfuehrer.
David Boder: Also die wurden direkt körperlich bestraft?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Nun und wie lange hat das gedauert, wie lange waren Sie dort in Neustadt?
Anna Braun: In Neustadt waren wir ..... fast ein (1) Jahr.
David Boder: Und das war schon welches Jahr?
Anna Braun: Es war .... drei und vierzig (43) kamen wir hin ..... bis vier und vierzig (44) Dezember.
David Boder: Bis Dezember vier und vierzig (44) und was hat dann passiert?
Anna Braun: Dann wurde die, die Versuchsanstalt, wo ich gearbeitet habe, wurde auch evakuiert nach Tschechoslowakei.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Anna Braun: Da kam sie nach Tschechoslowakei. Dort haben wir weiter gearbeitet. Da mussten alle, die dabei arbeiteten, die mussten mit. So bin ich persönlich eine Zeitlang mit meiner Familie von den anderen Mennoniten getrennt gewesen; das war vier (4) Monate lang in der Tschechoslowakei. Dann wurden wir auch von dort fort und sollten nach München, direkt nach München. Soweit kamen wir nicht, ungefähr sechzig (60) Kilometer vor München waren schon die Amerikaner.
David Boder: In was für Zügen hat man Sie geschickt?
Anna Braun: Wir fuhren auf Autos.
David Boder: Personenwagen?
Anna Braun: Lastwagen.
David Boder: Ja. Wie viele Leute auf einem Auto?
Anna Braun: Wir waren zwei und zwanzig (22) Mann auf einem Auto mit dem Gepäck.
David Boder: Also Sie saßen auf Ihrem Gepäck.
Anna Braun: Wir saßen auf unserem Gepäck.
David Boder: Nun und 60 Meilen vor München kamen die Amerikaner.
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Wer kam da? Erzählen Sie uns von der Befreiung.
Anna Braun: Wir kamen nach Heilenbach bei Rosenheim mit unserem Auto an . Da hat uns unser Transportführer verlassen. Er sagte, die Amerikaner müssen bald kommen und da hat er uns einfach in dem kleinen Örtchen gelassen und ... also er ist mit dem Auto weggegangen. Wir standen da auf der Strasse. Kein Mensch wollte uns aufnehmen. Es regnete, wir waren alle nass. (Hustet)
David Boder: Wie viele Leute ungefähr waren sie?
Anna Braun: Wir waren zwei und zwanzig Mann.
David Boder: Also das war bloß ein Auto?
Anna Braun: Es war ein Auto, die anderen Autos hatten wir verloren.
David Boder: Wer war der Führer? War er ein SS Mann oder was war er?
Anna Braun: Der Führer war ein Ingenieur bei der Firma, wo wir gearbeitet haben. Er hieß Larson und war ein Schwede selbst. Aber hat .... hat in diesem Betrieb für die Deutschen gearbeitet – bewusst. Und nachher – er hat uns eben so belogen, so betrogen, er hat all unser Gepäck also fast gestohlen, muss man sagen und hat noch einen Anhänger .....
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: ... und er hat noch einen Anhänger an unserem Auto, da war auch Gepäck von uns. Und der Anhänger musste auf einer Stelle gelassen werden und wir haben unsere Sachen niemals wieder zu sehen gekriegt, obwohl er uns fest versprochen hat, dieselben zu bringen.
David Boder: Hm.
Anna Braun: Wir haben ihn nachher nicht wieder gesehen. Aber später haben wir erfahren, dass er verhaftet wurde in Frankfurt am Main.
David Boder: Von wem?
Anna Braun: Er wurde verhaftet von den .... von den Amerikanern ....
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: .... und später gerichtet und auf zwölf (12) Jahre verurteilt, von einem amerikanischen Gericht auf zwölf (12) Jahre verurteilt; später vom schwedischen Gericht nochmals zwölf (12) Jahre). Also im Ganzen vier und zwanzig (24) Jahre hat er bekommen.
David Boder: Ja. Nun also, er hat sie einfach verlassen.
Anna Braun: Er hat uns verlassen!
David Boder: Und was ist dann passiert? Die Leute im Dorf wollten sie nicht reinlassen.
Anna Braun: Die Leute im Dorf wollten uns nicht reinlassen. Wir sind zum Bürgermeister gegangen und zum Lagerfuehrer, denn es war dort auch ein Lager in dem Dorf. Aber es wollte uns kein Lagerfuehrer, kein Bürgermeister aufnehmen. Wir saßen auf der Strasse mit den wenigen Habseligkeiten, die wir noch hatten und waren ganz nass, es regnete. (hustet) Nach allem Bitten gar nicht (unverständlich). Ich war, weil ich die Älteste von allen war, ich klopfe immer an und ich bitten gehen musste, und alle sitzen auf der Strasse und haben alle geweint. (scheint auch zu weinen).
David Boder: Waren da Männer und Frauen?
Anna Braun: Es waren nur Frauen (hustet) außer einem Mann, der ein Bein verloren hat.
David Boder: Nun.
Anna Braun: Es war ein Junger, ein Junger, der zufällig auf dem Wege auf uns gestoßen war. Er gehörte nicht zu unserer Firma oder zu unseren Arbeitern, den haben wir auf Auto ....
David Boder: Also, Sie sagen, dass alle, die auf diesem Wagen waren, waren das alle Mennoniten?
Anna Braun: Nein.
David Boder: Was waren das für Menschen?
Anna Braun: Es waren Leute aus Russland, von Leningrad.
David Boder: Christen?
Anna Braun: Christen, ja.
David Boder: Nun und wie ist es weiter in diesem Dorf gegangen?
Anna Braun: Wie bitte?
David Boder: Haben die Leute dort gewusst, dass die Amerikaner kommen?
Anna Braun: Die Leute haben gewusst, dass die Amerikaner kommen.
David Boder: Und dennoch wollten sie nicht ....
Anna Braun: und dennoch wollten sie nichts von uns wissen. Wir lagen so einen ganzen Tag auf der Strasse im Regen.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Dann ging ich wieder zum Bürgermeister und baten, schließen baten wir, er soll uns wenigstens ein Dach in der Schule geben. Da hat er uns gesagt, es kommt Militärmacht – sehr viel - und die Schule ist beschlagnahmt alle Klassen sind beschlagnahmt, für uns ist kein Raum, für uns zwei und zwanzig (22) Mann.
David Boder: Sie meinen zwei und zwanzig (22) Frauen.
Anna Braun: Zwei und zwanzig (22) Frauen.
David Boder: War Ihre Tochter mit Ihnen? Die beiden Kinder mit Ihnen?
Anna Braun: Beiden Kinder waren bei mir. Dann (räuspert sich) fast auf unseren Knien haben wir diesen Mann gebeten und schließlich abends .... er hatte Angst, wir würden in sein Haus kommen .... er hat uns schließlich gesagt: ‚Ihr dürft in die Schule gehen solange das Militär kommt. Aber wenn das Militär kommt und wenn es ist in mitten der Nacht, dann schmeiß ich Euch raus.’ Dann gingen wir in die Schule. Und das Militär kam wirklich nachts an. (hm, räuspert sich) Wir würden aber in dem Raum nicht gestört bis morgens zehn (10) Uhr. Aber morgens zehn (10) Uhr warf man uns raus.
David Boder: (in English) This concludes Spool number one hundred thirty three (133), (Pause), a report of Mrs. Anna Braun, a widow of the Mennonite, whose spouse perished or was executed in Russia.
David Boder: Munich, September 20, 1946. This is Spool number one hundred thirty four (134) a continuation of the report of a Mennonite woman, Mrs. Anna Braun, age forty (40), widow, who went through the war (cannot understand) and then came to Germany, where she did forced labor technical drawing and we stopped in the middle of the story, where they were abandoned by their, hm, escort, when the Americans approached and the military came to town, where they could not get any kind of accommodations and where they were allowed to sleep over in a school and we are now at what happened the next morning.
David Boder: (in deutsch) Also was hatten Sie den nächsten Tag?
Anna Braun: Um zehn Uhr morgens wurden wir aus der Schule geworfen .... da sind wir wieder .... vom Bürgermeister wurden wir rausgeworfen. Da sind wir wieder in ein Lager gekommen, wo viele Flüchtlinge waren. Da wurden wir schließlich aufgenommen.
David Boder: Wer waren die Flüchtlinge im Lager?
Anna Braun: Es waren die meisten Flüchtlinge aus Jugoslawien.
David Boder: Nun was passierte weiter?
Anna Braun: Dort haben wir drei Tage ... kriegten wir ... also wir wurden dort als Gäste aufgenommen. Drei Tage kriegten wir dann kein Essen und dann kam ... schließlich musste dieses Lager wieder geräumt werden, denn auch dorthin sollte Militär kommen.
David Boder: Wo war das? Sechzig (60) Meilen von München?
Anna Braun: Das war sechzig (60) Meilen von München.
David Boder: Wie heißt diese Stadt?
Anna Braun: Heilenbach bei Rosenheim. Es ist keine Stadt, aber ein schöner Ort in Bayern, eine schöne Ecke in den Bergen.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Dort sollten wir auch wieder rausgeworfen werden, weil das Lazarett .... weil das Lazarett hinein kommen sollte.
David Boder: Also was für Flüchtlinge waren dort?
Anna Braun: Es waren dort Flüchtlinge aus Jugoslawien und Rumänien.
David Boder: Nicht Arbeiter, nicht verschleppte Personen?
Anna Braun: Ja, alles Verschleppte, es waren alles verschleppte Personen.
David Boder: Kein Juden?
Anna Braun: Keine Juden.
David Boder: Nun?
Anna Braun: Dann war eine Zeitlang ...... also das deutsche, das deutsche Lazarett kam herein. Die waren etliche Tage da. Und wir ..... man hatte uns in einige Zimmer zusammen getan und noch nicht raus geworfen. Es sollte jeden Tag passieren, aber da kamen die Amerikaner, die amerikanischen Soldaten. Dieses Rote Kreuz – also das Lazarett, das Deutsche wurde sofort von den amerikanischen Soldaten beschlagnahmt und die haben da den Befehl gegeben, dass man uns nicht rauswerfen kann.
David Boder: Was waren die Soldaten? Waren die zu Fuß? In Tanks? In Automobilen? Wo waren die?
Anna Braun: Nein, die waren auf Tanks und auf Automobilen. Es kamen nur ganz wenige Autos, ich denke es waren fünf (5) oder sechs (6) Autos im Ganzen kamen dort hin. Das war alles. Die haben dieses Lager beschlagnahmt und wir kriegten bald darauf ... Lebensmittelkarten kriegten wir keine, die kriegte das Lager, aber wir kriegten da allgemeine Verpflegung.
David Boder: Haben Sie etwas Geld mit sich gehabt?
Anna Braun: Wir hatten nur ganz wenig Geld.
David Boder: Hat man Ihnen für Ihre Arbeit gezahlt in Neustadt?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Was hat man Ihnen gezahlt?
Anna Braun: Ich – als technische Zeichnerin – kriegte ..... hundert achtzig (180) Mark monatlich.
David Boder: Und Verpflegung?
Anna Braun: Die Verpflegung .... für Verpflegung und Wohnung extra gezahlt.
David Boder: Sie haben extra gezahlt?
Anna Braun: Habe ich extra gezahlt.
David Boder: Nun also, da sitzen Sie im Lager und das Lager wurde von Amerikanern, sagen Sie, beschlagnahmt.
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Und wer verwaltete das Lager?
Anna Braun: Das Lager wurde dann solange das Lazarett da war, immer vom Lazarett verwaltet.
David Boder: Aha.
Anna Braun: Denn der Lagerfuehrer, der gerade war, wie wir da kamen, den hat man ja sofort verhaftet. Den hat man sofort verhaftet, den haben sie nicht mehr gesehen. Und so wurde das ... das Lager vier (4) Wochen lang vom Lazarett verwaltet. Wie das Lazarett weg ging, dann ...........
David Boder: Es war ein amerikanisches Lazarett?
Anna Braun: Nein, das war ein deutsches Lazarett. Ja, und dieses deutsche Lazarett ....
David Boder: Und blieben die deutschen Schwestern, die deutschen Ärzte, die blieben alle dort?
Anna Braun: Die blieben vorläufig dort und die haben uns auch verwaltet.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, wie haben die sich dann benommen, wie die Amerikaner schon da waren?
Anna Braun: Oh, wie die Amerikaner da waren, haben sie sich sehr gut benommen.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, Frau Braun, Sie sprechen ja deutsch, haben sie mit den Deutschen bevor der Befreiung oder nach der Befreiung ein bisserl geredet? Was haben die von der ganzen Sache gedacht?
Anna Braun: Es waren unter den Deutschen sehr verschiedene Leute. Die Deutschen haben sich, so viel wie ich es am Anfang gehört habe, da haben sie sich ... - viele, die Meisten wohl, - anders gedacht. Doch wurden sie von der ganzen – also von dem Führer und seinen Anhängern so beeinflusst, nicht, dass sie langsam glauben mussten, dass sie die Sache wohl die Richtige sehen. Im Stillen aber, das hat man doch oft gedacht, ich kenne doch viele von den Deutschen, die mir gesagt haben: ‚Eigentlich glauben wir nicht daran - eigentlich glauben wir nicht daran, aber wir müssen’s glauben, nicht. Wir bilden es uns ein und glauben.’ Richtige Anhänger hatte der Führer wohl nur Wenige.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie, wenn der Führer nur so wenige richtige Anhänger hatte, wie erklären Sie – Sie wissen doch, wie es den Juden in den Lagern gegangen ist .....
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Wie erklären Sie das?
Anna Braun: Oft habe ich an die deutschen Soldaten gedacht: wie kann man bloß so was machen? Zum Beispiel, gerade wegen den Juden, nicht. Über die Frage ... also über diese Frage konnte ich mich niemals beruhigen und ich habe immer wieder die Frage erwähnt. Gerade so auch wie mit dem ‚Heil Hitler’ Gruß. Ich konnte niemals verstehen, warum man – da wir also als Mennoniten so religiös waren und wir auch nur für uns – also in dem „Vater Unser” heißt es also „geheiligt werde Dein Name”, nicht, also nur das ist der Name der geheiligt werde. Und da habe ich dann gesagt: ‚Warum heiligt ihr des Führers Name? Das ist nicht richtig. Gerade so ist es nicht richtig, wie ihr die Juden behandelt, die Juden umbringt, oder auch die Juden, die sind ein auserwähltes Volk.’
David Boder: Haben Sie gewusst, wie es den Juden geht?
Anna Braun: Wer – ich? Natürlich. Ja
David Boder: Wieso haben Sie es gewusst?
Anna Braun: Ja, es waren ja auch in der Gegend, wo wir gewohnt haben, viele Juden. Und, die Juden verschwanden ja auch, verschwanden ja auch.
David Boder: Sie meinen die Gegend Neustadt, wo Sie gewohnt haben?
Anna Braun: Nein, da weiß ich weniger. Ich meinte da in Russland.
David Boder: Sie meinen während in Ihrer Zeit in Russland sind die Juden weggenommen ....
Anna Braun: Ja, in Russland haben die Deutschen die Juden weggenommen und viel deutsche Soldaten haben mir auch erzählt, was sie mit den Juden machen, nicht.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Das hat man erfahren sogar eine der Ünsrigen – die Mennoniten dürfen ja keine anderen Religionen und keine anderen Nationen heiraten, nicht. Aber weil bei uns eine Mennonitin einen Juden geheiratet hatte, .....
Anna Braun: ... die hatte auch ein Kind von einem Juden. Deshalb weiß ich diese Sache, zum Beispiel, ganz genau, nicht. Von den Anderen hört man nur von Hörensagen, nicht, was den Juden passiert, da wusste man nicht, soll man es glauben oder ist es wirklich so furchtbar. Aber diese Frau, der hat man noch das Kind weggenommen hatte, weil es einen Juden als Vater hatte und das Kind umgebracht hat, da haben wir gewusst, was man mit den Juden macht. Dieses Kind hat man vergiftet.
David Boder: Wieso? Hat die Frau das wirklich gewusst?
Anna Braun: Sie hat es vorher nicht gewusst, dass man es in dem Moment vergiftet, aber es sind die deutschen Soldaten gekommen, die hatten den Befehl. Und unter diesen waren solche, die kein Herz hatten.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Und haben das Kind geholt. Es war so ein liebes, kleines, blondes lockiges Kind, lange Haare hatte es. Ein kleines Mädel und wie sie kamen das Kind holen, hat mancher Deutsche auch gesagt: ‚Ich kann das nicht, ich kann das Kind nicht der Mutter weg nehmen’. Aber eines Tages (räuspert sich – sie scheint zu weinen) – die Mutter hat das nicht her gegeben – und eines Tages hat man mit einem Auto die Mutter geholt mit dem Kind nach Zaporozhe. Dann hat man das Kind auf der Fahrt nach Zaporozhe vergiftet. Man hat irgendwie unter der Nase was gemacht ..... mit dem Finger, die Frau hat das nicht bemerkt. Mit einem Mal hält sie ihr steifes, totes Kind.
David Boder: Ist die Frau zurück gekommen?
Anna Braun: Ja. Die Frau kam zurück, ich glaube man hat die Frau zurück gebracht und sie war dann wochenlang zu Hause krank gelegen. Das Kind hat sie immer gerufen.
David Boder: Hat sie das Kind beerdigt?
Anna Braun: So viel ich weiß, nein.
David Boder: Aha. Nun da haben Sie gewohnt für einen Monat mit dem deutschen Roten Kreuz. Was ist dann passiert?
Anna Braun: Dann wurden die deutschen Soldaten entlassen oder verschickt, das weiß ich nicht. Dann (hustet) blieben die Verschleppten und Flüchtlinge in dem Lager zurück. Da wurde unter den Flüchtlingen und Verschleppten, dann ein Mann gewählt, nicht. Und dann kam ein neuer Bürgermeister, der uns sagt, also der und der soll jetzt das Lager führen und die Verwaltung führen und in der Küche soll einen neuer Koch gewählt werden, hin gestellt werden. Und so kam auch ich in die Lagerküche als zweite (2.) Köchin.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Da habe ich dann neun (9) Monate lang gekocht.
David Boder: Wer hat die Verpflegung besorgt?
Anna Braun: Die Verpflegung mussten ..... die Verpflegung musste dann aufs Wirtschaftsamt darum fragen.
David Boder: War das ein deutsches Wirtschaftsamt oder haben die schon die Verpflegung von den Amerikanern bekommen?
Anna Braun: Nein, wir haben dann schon die Verpflegung von den Amerikanern bekommen.
David Boder: War es die UNNRA schon?
Anna Braun: Nein, die UNNRA war es nicht.
David Boder: Hm, weiter.
Anna Braun: Dann nach neun Monaten – wir haben dort gearbeitet neun (9) Monate lang, aber kein Geld bekommen. Das Essen war aber auch unentgeltlich. Wir haben aber im Lager gearbeitet, kein Geld bekommen. Ich habe von früh bis spät gearbeitet. Und (hustet) da wir aber gar kein Geld mehr hatten – unser Geld ging auf – wir hatten gar kein Geld. Und für Schuhe und für Kleidung und zur Operation brauchten wir Geld. Da habe ich zum meiner Tochter gesagt, wir können nicht mehr im Lager bleiben, wir müssen uns Arbeit suchen, wo wir angestellt sind, damit wir auch etwas verdienen. Und so sind gegangen zum Arbeitsamt und bekamen auch eine Arbeit in .... neun (9) Kilometer ab von Heilenbach, in einer Seifenfabrik. Da, weil ich herzleidend bin .....
David Boder: Seit wann haben sie ein Herzleiden?
Anna Braun: Schon 20 Jahr. Hab ich nur einen halben (½) Tag gearbeitet. Da kriege ich nur sehr dicke Beine vom Stehen und sah auch ein, dass ich diese Arbeit nicht mehr tun konnte. Uns reicht aber der Verdienst zum Leben nicht. Wir verdienten ... in der Woche sechs und zwanzig (26) Mark zusammen mit der Tochter, zu zweit und gaben allein fürs Essen acht und zwanzig (28) Mark aus. Dann blieb uns für Schuh Reparatur und so weiter kein Geld.
David Boder: Wollen Sie mir etwas sagen, was sind die Preise, wenn man frei, hm, sozusagen in Deutschland lebt und mit sechs und zwanzig (26) Mark. Was kostet das Brot in Deutschland?
Anna Braun: Also man kann mit sechs und zwanzig (26) Mark ... kann man nur auf Karten leben. Da kann man schon nichts so nebenbei bei den Bauern kaufen. Da darf man schon nur die Sachen aufkaufen, die auf den Lebensmittel, ..... die es auf den Lebensmittelkarten gibt.
David Boder: Also die deutschen Bauern führen einen Schwarzhandel, nicht wahr?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Die deutschen Bauern führen einen Schwarzhandel.
David Boder: Und sie verkaufen Lebensmittel wofür, für Geld oder für was?
Anna Braun: Wir sind niemals zu den Bauern gegangen, weil wir kein Geld hatten. Für großes Geld kauft man da, man kann alles haben von den Bauern. Das sollte nicht sein, aber schwarz kann man es schon haben damals. Und wir waren in der Seifenfabrik nur ganz. kurze Zeit, anderthalb (1½) Monate. Dann ..... kriegten wir Nachricht von unseren Verwandten
David Boder: Aus wo?
Anna Braun: Aus München, die sich hier in diesem Lager befanden in der Funkkaserne.
David Boder: Ja, wieso haben Sie Nachricht bekommen? Wie ist das zu Stande gekommen?
Anna Braun: Ein Telegramm kriegten wir.
David Boder: Wie haben die gewusst, wo Sie sind?
Anna Braun: Also ich wusste – wir haben schon erfahren, dass meine Verwandten sich bei Hof in einem kleinen Bauerndorf befanden. Die Nachricht hatten wir schon. Dann auf einmal erhalten wir ein Telegramm aus München: ‚Wir sind hier in München in der Funkkaserne’. Man hat erfahren, dass es hier ein Immigrierungslager gibt in München und da wir schon von je her nach Amerika auswandern wollten, dann sind unsere Verwandten sofort hierher nach München gekommen und haben sofort uns auch ein Telegramm geschickt, damit wir auch herkamen.
David Boder: Aha. Nun sagen Sie mal, hm, hm, wohin planen Sie zu gehen?
Anna Braun: Wir wollen nach Britisch Kolumbien, nach Kanada.
David Boder: Wen haben Sie dort?
Anna Braun: Das sind meines Mannes Brüder; drei Brüder hat mein Mann dort.
David Boder: Und wie heißt die Stadt in Britisch Kolumbien? Wissen Sie, wo sie sind?
Anna Braun: Koch.... hm, hm, ....
David Boder: Nun, also recht, weiter. Gibt es viele Mennoniten there, dort?
Anna Braun: In Kanada gibt es sehr viele Mennoniten.
David Boder: Und in Britisch Kolumbien?
Anna Braun: In Britisch Kolumbien auch viel.
David Boder: Nun, sagen Sie mal, stehen Sie schon in Verbindung mit denen, haben sie Ihnen Affidavits geschickt?
Anna Braun: Ja, wir haben schon die Bürgschaft erhalten. Auch, auch in den Briefen schreibt mein Schwager, der uns die Bürgschaft schickt, dass er unsere Reise schon angezahlt hat und sie hoffen, dass wir zu Weihnachten schon dort sind.
David Boder: Warum soll das so lange dauern?
Anna Braun: Die Sachen .... Die Auswanderungssache oder Einwanderungssache in Kanada ist immer noch nicht fertig. Die einzelnen Provinzen sind schon einverstanden, aber es muss wohl noch .....
David Boder: Bestätigt werden.
Anna Braun: Bestätigt werden.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir mal, diese ganze Zeit waren Sie mit Ihrer Stieftochter. Das ist eine persönliche Frage – wie haben sie zusammen, wie leben sie zusammen, wie versorgen sie sich?
Anna Braun: Wir vertragen uns sehr gut, wir leben sehr gut zusammen und wir möchten auch nicht auseinander.
David Boder: Nun gibt es noch irgend etwas, was Sie uns sagen wollten, Frau Braun?
Anna Braun: Ich kann nur noch hinzufügen, dass mein .... wir waren vier (4) Geschwister, (räuspert sich) – von diesen vier (4) Geschwistern bin ich alleine übrig geblieben. Mein Bruder wurde auch im Jahre neunzehn hundert fünf und dreißig von der GPU zum Tode verurteilt. Er hat Monate lang in der Totenkammer gesessen. Nachdem wir alles versucht haben, all unsere Mittel dem Advokaten gegeben haben, damit sie alles dran setzen und wenigstens das Todesurteil abändern. Das ist uns gelungen, da hat man das Todesurteil abgeändert auf fünf und zwanzig (25) Jahre. Doch mein Bruder ist nach zwei Jahren im Gefängnis gestorben.
David Boder: Wofür hat man ihn verurteilt? Doch nicht weil er Mennonite war?
Anna Braun: Nein, aber er war im Kirchenrat gewesen und weil er ..... wir durften doch dort .... es war nicht religionsfrei ... wir durften Religion zu letzt nicht haben und, hm, da hat mein Bruder doch bis zuletzt immer wieder versucht, damit wir doch unsere Kirche halten können, nicht, dafür verschwand er eines Tages. Mehr wissen wir nicht. Man hat nachher gesagt, weil er ein Radio hat, weil das Radio hat man vielleicht mit ihm weggenommen.
David Boder: Na, da durfte man kein Radio haben?
Anna Braun: Offiziell war es nicht verboten, aber wenn die Mennoniten Radios hatten, dann wurden die alle weggenommen. Und meinem Bruder wurde es genommen, wie man ihn verhaftet hat. Er ist dann nach zwei Jahren im Gefängnis gestorben. Aber zu der Zeit – im Jahre neunzehn hundert fünf und dreißig da durften wir uns noch Briefe schreiben im Gefängnis. Und dann hat meine ..... wie ich schon einmal sagt, bei uns Mennoniten ist es nicht erlaubt eine andere Nation zu heiraten, oder einen anderen Glauben. Doch meine Schwester, meine jüngste Schwester hat einen Tataren geheiratet. Er war Ingenieur und kam daher von Leningrad bis zum Onega See. Sie arbeiten da an einer Verbindung der Kanäle.
David Boder: Bei Leningrad?
Anna Braun: Bei Leningrad, ja. Dort hat er gearbeitet
David Boder: Und was war das für ein See?
Anna Braun: Onega See.
David Boder: Oh, Onega See
Anna Braun: Onezhskoe ozero.
David Boder: Oh ja, Onezhskoe ozero. (sagt einen russischen Satz) (beiden lachen)
Anna Braun: Ja, und seitdem weiß ich von meiner Schwester nichts, wo sie geblieben ist.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Anna Braun: Dann war die andere Schwester, die war auch in Bartko.
David Boder: Wo?
Anna Braun: In Bartko, das ist Polen.
David Boder: Bartko?
Anna Braun: Bartigo, in Deutsch nannte man es Bartigo.
David Boder: Bartigo?
Anna Braun: Ja. Und da in Polen war sie und nachher haben wir sie nicht mehr gefunden. Doch durch Amerika – haben wir jetzt einen Karte von ihr erhalten. Sie hat eine Karte geschrieben aus dem Sibirien nach, hm, Amerika. Und unsere Verwandten aus Amerika haben uns die Karte abgeschrieben und zugeschickt, daher wissen wir heute die Anschrift von meiner Schwester, der ...
David Boder: Die Adresse?
Anna Braun: Ja, die Adresse von meiner Schwester.
David Boder: Na ja, in Sibirien – war sie dorthin verschickt oder... ?
Anna Braun: Wir wissen nichts.
David Boder: Das Leben in Sibirien selbst- ist ja nicht so schlecht.
Anna Braun: Nein, nein, das ist es auch nicht.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Das ist es auch nicht.
David Boder: Na, ja das ist schon wenigstens glücklich. Oh ja, sie war in Polen, ja, die Mennoniten von Polen wurden ja nach Sibirien geschickt.
Anna Braun: Ja, wahrscheinlich.
David Boder: Und so ist sie da leben geblieben.
Anna Braun: Ja, also wir wissen nicht, warum sie dorthin geschickt worden ist – das wissen wir nicht.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir, wie leben Sie hier in diesem Lager? Wieviel Mennoniten sind Sie und wie leben Sie hier?
Anna Braun: Wir sind hier schon bald sechs hundert (600) Mennoniten hier in dem Lager.
David Boder: Wieviel Männer, Frauen und Kinder?
Anna Braun: Es sind hier ungefähr ......
David Boder: Wenn Sie nicht .....
Anna Braun: .... ungefähr drei hundert (300) bis drei hundert fünfzig (350) Kinder.
David Boder: Oh ja.
Anna Braun: Ja. Dann sind Frauen, ............ der Rest sind Frauen und Männer. Darunter sind ja ganz .... die Meisten Frauen, Männer sind ja nur Wenige.
David Boder: Wieviel Frauen gibt es hier mit ihren Männern .... ungefähr?
Anna Braun: Es sind hier sehr wenige Frauen mit, mit Männern. Es ist entweder so – die Frauen ohne Männer und die Männer ohne Frauen.
David Boder: Nun haben welche geheiratet seit sie hier waren?
Anna Braun: Ja, eine Heirat.
David Boder: Eine.
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Und wie leben Sie? Haben Sie einen Block oder Haus für sich? Oder wie ist das?
Anna Braun: Ja, wir leben hier im Block.
David Boder: Ich habe leider keine Zeit in Ihren Block zu gehen und deshalb frage ich Sie.
Anna Braun: Ja, ja, wir leben hier im Block acht (8) – die meisten Mennoniten. Dann die Übrigen leben in Block vier und zwanzig (24) und in Block sechs (6).
David Boder: Also wie leben Sie da in, hm, in Block acht (8)? Sind es große Zimmer? Wie viele Leute ungefähr in einem Zimmer?
Anna Braun: Wir haben Zimmer von dreißig bis vierzig Quadratmeter (30 bis 40 m2) gross und in einem Zimmer wohnen zwölf (12) Mann.
David Boder: Ja.
Anna Braun: Das heißt Männer und Frauen, ja, aber wir haben unsere Betten wie die Zimmer geräumt sind, so eingeteilt, dass die Frauen von den Männern. Hm, .....
David Boder: Gedeckt.
Anna Braun: ..... gedeckt sind.
David Boder: Haben Sie Vorhänge oder so was?
Anna Braun: Ja, jedes Zimmer haben wir erstmals geteilt durch die hohen Doppelbetten, dann durch Decken und Handtuch noch die Winkel abge......
David Boder: Hm, ja,...... abgedeckt?
Anna Braun: Ja und wir leben hier in dem Lager sehr gut.
David Boder: Und wer sorgt hier für die Verpflegung?
Anna Braun: Unter uns Mennoniten – wir, die Arbeitsfähigen arbeiten hier alle.
David Boder: Und werden Sie bezahlt?
Anna Braun: Ja, das heißt, hm, wir kriegen bessere Verpflegung, besseres Essen, Arbeiterkarten und, hm, dazu kriegen sie eine Kleiderkarte, die arbeiten.
David Boder: Mit der Kleiderkarte wo kaufen sie sich ihre Kleider?
Anna Braun: Sie kriegen das Essen und Kleider unentgeltlich. Jeden Monat kriegt jeder Arbeiter zwei Kleidungsstücke. Es wird auf der Kleiderkarte dann angemerkt, was man bekommen hat.
David Boder: Arbeiten Sie?
Anna Braun: Ich arbeite auch, aber ich arbeite im (unverständlich) Passamt. Also arbeite ich eigentlich auch .... also ich arbeite für die (unverständlich), die kriege ich nicht bezahlt
David Boder: Arbeitet Ihre Tochter?
Anna Braun: Ja, meine Tochter ist Kindergärtnerin.
David Boder: Oh. Sie hat eine Arbeitskarte, nicht wahr?
Anna Braun: Ja, meine Tochter hat eine Arbeitskarte und sie kriegt für die Arbeit, hm, also Zigaretten.
David Boder: Zigaretten?
Anna Braun: Ja. (lacht)
David Boder: (lacht) Wie viele Zigaretten kriegt sie denn für ihre Arbeit?
Anna Braun: Sie kriegt ..... es war – früher war es mehr und jetzt hat man weniger, also gegenwärtig kriegt sie zehn (10) Pakete Zigaretten monatlich.
David Boder: Monatlich. Das sind zwei hundert (200) Zigaretten.
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Raucht sie?
Anna Braun: Nein.
David Boder: Nun wollen Sie mir mal sagen, wollen Sie uns erzählen, was tut man dann mit den Zigaretten?
Anna Braun: Also mit den Zigaretten – da macht man, hm, ..... also sagen wir mal, wir wollen die Schuhe reparieren. Wir haben kein Geld, so zahlen wir mit Zigaretten dafür.
David Boder: Ah ja und wie viel Zigaretten geben Sie für ein paar Sohlen?
Anna Braun: (lacht etwas) So genau kann ich das nicht sagen.
David Boder: Ja so ungefähr sagen Sie es.
Anna Braun: Ein Paket Zigaretten für ein paar Sohlen.
David Boder: Und da wird er schon das Leder damit besorgen?
Anna Braun: Ja, alles.
David Boder: Ja. Nun das ist ja sehr interessant. Und sagen Sie, was machen dann die Anderen, wer raucht Zigaretten, wenn alle mit Zigaretten handeln?
Anna Braun: Die Männer rauchen Zigaretten.
David Boder: Also die Männer rauchen.
Anna Braun: Von den Mennoniten Frauen raucht niemand.
David Boder: Oh, die Frauen, die Mennoniten Frauen rauchen nicht.
Anna Braun: Es ist nicht erlaubt, weil das die Religion ist.
David Boder: Aber Sie bekommen Zigaretten?
Anna Braun: Ja.
David Boder: Bekommen die allgemeine Einwohner vom Lager Zigaretten?
Anna Braun: Nein, wer nicht arbeitet, kriegt keine Zigaretten.
David Boder: Well, nun, Frau Braun, es hat mir wirklich eine große Genugtuung gemacht mit Ihnen zu reden. Und höre gerne wenn sie russisch sprechen, sie sprechen ja ausgezeichnet.
Anna Braun: Ich spreche russisch, ja, aber so sicher bin ich mir doch nicht in russisch.
David Boder: Auf der Schule haben Sie russisch gelernt?
Anna Braun: Ja, russisch und auch deutsch.
David Boder: Nun, ich danke Ihnen sehr. Ich glaube, Sie haben mir sehr wichtiges Material gegeben und ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Geduld.
Anna Braun: Bitte.
David Boder: (In English) This completes, hm, this makes it, hm, twenty five (25) minutes on Spool number hundred thirty four (134), which concluded from Spool number hundred thirty three (133) – the interview with Mrs. Anna Braun, a Mennonite widow, who is now here at the Funkkaserne, Munich, a detention camp with a Mennonite colony of about five hundred (500) people. An Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording. I am now using this spool to the end ... (cannot understand) .... the interview.